So now we have this graph
of this-- what was
clearly a trig function.
And our task is to figure
out what the function is.
So let's look at this.
The first thing I do when I
look at something like this,
I want to figure out its
period and its amplitude.
So what's its amplitude?
That's always an easy one.
So the amplitude.
Well, that's just how much does
it move up and down above
and below the x-axis?
Well, the amplitude here is how
much it moves up the x-axis.
Well, it moves up 1/2 above
and below the x-axis.
So the amplitude is 1/2.
And keep in mind, the amplitude
is not this whole distance.
It's not this.
It's just how much it moves
above or below the x-axis.
So in this case, the
amplitude is 1/2.
And then we have to figure
out what the period is.
The period is, how long does it
take-- how many radians does
it go through for it to go
through 1 complete cycle?
Well, if we start here, and we
were to follow the graph, it
doesn't take until right here
until we complete
1 cycle, right?
Because here, we're still
going down, and now
we're going below.
So we're not repeating yet.
And here's where we
start repeating again.
And then we start
repeating again here.
So every pi radians, we
start the cycle over again.
It happens the same if you
go backwards into the
negative radians.
So the period is pi, right?
The period is pi.
And you could start
from any point.
You could start
from this point.
And if you go, follow the
graph, and then come back to
the same point again, we
see once again that the
period is pi radians.
Now we have to figure out
if this is a sine or
a cosine function.
And for now, we'll not
think about shifting.
So let's think about what
happens when-- you know,
we want to know what
this function is.
f of x is equal to
question mark.
Well, we see that f of 0 is 0.
f of 0 is equal to 0.
What does that tell us?
Is this a sine or a
cosine function?
Well, what's cosine of 0?
Cosine of 0 is 1.
And what's sine of 0?
Well, sine of 0 is 0.
And this function is 0.
So we know that this
is a sine function.
So we know the formula is going
to take the form f of x, it's
going to equal the amplitude
times sine of 2 pi
over the period x.
And if we just substitute these
numbers we just figured out, we
know that f of x is equal to
1/2 sine of 2 pi over pi x.
The pi's cancel out and
you get f of x is equal
to 1/2 sine of 2x.
Let's define another function.
Let's define g of x is
equal to 1/2 cosine of 2x.
What would have
this looked like?
Or what would have-- yeah.
The grammar's a
little difficult.
I picked the wrong color,
because f of x is
actually the pink one.
This is the one we have now.
So actually, let
me circle that.
This is f of x.
f of x is this one right here.
And now, g of x,
I'm going to do--.
So when x is 0, what is g of 0?
Let's put 0 in here.
So this whole term
will become 0.
What's cosine of 0?
It's 1.
And 1 times 1/2.
So g of 0 is 1/2.
So we would start here, and
then we would have-- just
like the sine function-- we
would have a period of pi.
Because it has the same
coefficient here.
So this'll just look like this.
I think you get the point.
It's just like the sine
function was just shifted
to the left of it.
Well, I'm getting confused
on this-- ignore this.
But if you look at this side,
the important thing to realize
is that it intersects the
y-axis at not 1, but 1/2.
And the reason why it doesn't
intersect it at 1, even
though cosine of 0 is 1, is
because we have this 1/2
coefficient right here.
I guess you can't call
that a coefficient.
I guess it's a 1/2 times
the cosine function.
Hopefully that gives you a
little bit more of a sense of,
if you just looked at a graph,
being able to figure
out its equation.
And I'll actually do one more
video where we'll actually use
the Khan Academy trig
graphing module to figure
out a couple more.
See you soon.